dancy nor is a former senior advisor to
Paul Ryan and Mitt Romney in the 2012
presidential campaign he's been talking
with Republican members of Congress
about the president's immigration push
Dan good morning good morning Portia
good saying this immigration focus well
I think you got a strip these issues
apart
I think the caravan issue does raise
legitimate policy issues I mean
regardless of how it's been hyped the
reality is if you look what's happened
in Europe where you've had this massive
migration crisis millions of people
coming in and no real effort to stop it
it's it's completely unsettled European
parlament politics Merkel just stepped
down or announced that she's stepping
down in Germany in part because of the
politics of this so it's time from her
party from her party right which means
she won't be able to run again so the
idea that we should have a serious
policy to make sure that that doesn't
happen here is legitimate when thousands
of people seem to be coming to the US we
need some kind of policy my impression
is from a policy standpoint that's
legitimate and politically it's good
where I think where the president went
too far is on this birthright
citizenship issue for several reasons
one what he's proposing is
unconstitutional too
he said sort of in a flip way not
coordinated with anyone in the
congressional leadership I'll just do
this by executive order in a response to
a question from a reporter that seemed
to be goading him a little bit and it
just conveyed chaos and I think the
biggest risk to the Republicans heading
into these midterms is not the
president's policy agenda but as the is
conveying chaos and the way he's been
handling some of the immigration issue
reinforces chaos what do you make of his
attack on how Speaker Paul Ryan in as it
as it pertains to the birthright issue
so so Ryan had been campaigning so
basically I think there's a very good
chance Republicans are gonna hang on to
the Senate or pick up a seat I also
think there's a very good chance that
the Republicans are gonna lose the house
and if they lose the house they're gonna
lose districts in New York State in New
Jersey in California in suburban
Virginia and in these districts which
are basically suburban districts middle
class upper middle class districts
talking about a chaotic executive order
to unearth a constitutional guarantee
about birthright citizenship does not
play well and Ryan was in one of those
districts when he was given the
interview when he responded to what the
president said Ryan both believes it's
it's a mistake I'm sorry that policy and
B he thinks
bad for the members who seats he's
trying to save Ryan's in the middle of
this 25 city tour right now trying to
hang on to the Republican majority so he
had to respond the president punch back
I think that's where it ends and the
only reason it ends there is because the
two of them basically have a good
working relationship so neither wants to
escalate but more importantly the flurry
of news events I mean I wake up every
day I know about you guys yeah spend
like 8:30 I'm exhausted yeah right like
there's just so much going on we've got
I thought to myself we've got five days
left before midterms my math is like
that's about 34 tweets if you know do
five six tweets a day from the president
so we're in this constant flurry and and
this little skirmish with Ryan just
won't you know so you're no big deal
yeah many tweets more over the weekend
so we could see more tweets all right
that's it dance thanks so much